i don't really see you know a lot of
homophobic and racist comments anymore
because people really know that it's not
okay and it is not okay that was 90 day
fiance star alina kashevnikova speaking
to et about discrimination just weeks
ago which feels ironic now because tlc
fired the 27 year old from the franchise
over her resurfaced racist social media
posts now it's gonna change i'm just
hoping it's not gonna mess everything up
in a statement to et the network says it
cut all ties with the star due to the
offensive posts which mock different
races and religions quote tlc
discontinued filming with alina she will
not appear on the upcoming tell-all or
any future seasons of the franchise tlc
does not tolerate racism or
discrimination of any kind people
usually tend to jump into
different assumptions so quickly
and without like knowing the context and
everything else in one unearthed post
alini reportedly used the n-word
multiple times while describing a party
she was invited to and in another
featuring alina wearing traditional
indian clothing she made a joke about
polygamy in the caption i feel like
maybe sometimes it's not the best thing
to do before tlc fired elena the 90 day
star spoke out on social media writing
quote despite what's being said about me
my friends family and those who met me
in person know who i really am and who i
am not and i know it too the answers are
coming hi
i'm gonna hug you
you're smaller than i thought is it
weird for you
it's different
as the hit franchise's first little
person to be featured on the show the
russian native made history i just
think that it's awesome and i kind of
love that i'm the first one because i'm
not really compared to anyone else
this season of 90 day fiance before the
90 days features alina's love story with
caleb greenwood from arizona it's just
like we clicked our sense of humor is
kind of similar the two first connected
online at age 15 but lost touch for 13
years they reunited years later when
they matched by chance on a dating app
he has aspirations in life so that just
really attracted me and he seemed like
uh someone
who i want to get to know better and
someone i can confide in because we also
know each other for such a long time one
thing alina wanted to bring awareness to
while on the show was the insensitivity
surrounding ableism which is
discrimination in favor of able-bodied
people for some reason there is not much
talk about ableism
and how people
can say
degrading things about those who have
disabilities and i just want to see how
you know maybe something can change with
the show because more people
would know that it's not okay to
i don't know
shame someone for their height or for
like using a wheelchair or something
you